plus
c'est le 4 à la suisse le 4 à la suisse
et rsa je vous ai cliqué pour répondre à
la question n'est pas de buzzer car nous
n'avons pas d'argent c'est très simple
c'est un petit suisse bien sûr un petit
suisse
attention où lee perry mais bien entendu
là encore on voulait répondre ne le fait
pas tout de suite
bayon voulait répondre vous mettez le
petit suisse là dessus et vous faites
comme sent bon faut pas manger manger
elle mange pas la manche mais sans
manger mais sont pas permis je pense pas
bien sûr mais alors les chéris mais
question asie hier les internautes ont
critiqué une candidate de l'émission
mariée au premier regard pourquoi des
propos sexistes pour s'être battu pour
avoir fait une crise ou pour s'être
marié avec gilles verdez car avec fatou
ça n'avançait pas non mais oh t'as
compris devant la télé
tu est sauvé je saurai ya au cours de
l'émission les candidats ont pu
découvrir un nouveau couple elodie et
joachim mélodie a suscité une petite
polémique sur les réseaux pascal a
prononcé une phrase jugée sexiste
on va voir ce qu'elle a dit et vous nous
direz ce que vous en pensez c'est parti
fort que je cuisine et je me dis il
manque du sol de sa cuisine comme ça
mais pour partager ce moment là avec toi
mon avis allait faire
les multiples a donc l'apprentissage
commence maintenant
c'est pas grand chose mais j'ai pas
l'habitude de cuisiner
donc pour moi c'est déjà du grand
changement je me plonge dans le rôle de
femme
dès maintenant alors nous dit ça ça a
été jugée sexiste
qu'est ce qu'on s'est relâché vous
jubert des mois j'ai été extrêmement
choqué parce que c'est une vision
archaïque du rôle de la femme on peut
pas laisser dire ça aujourd'hui
enfin cette candidate en plus je trouve
que c'était un moment de sincérité mais
voilà c'était la meilleure le meilleur
coupé elle gâche tout par sa non on peut
pas aujourd'hui tenir des propos comme
ça
choquée à la maison quand j'entends ce
que tu dis mais enfin on va passer me
voir tourner deux secondes et demie mais
qu'on femme dit j'aime bien faire la
cuisine
pas franchement faut pas arrêter de
boire de sexisme partout et y compris là
où on n'a pas forcément vraiment de nous
voir alors pour tout et n'importe quoi
ceci n'est que des tas de gens choqués
quand même difficile il ya eu des tas de
georges ugeux oui oui moyens non pas le
choquer donc l'usiné quand même que
c'est vous paye appelle des shows qui
voudraient parler ouais tu dis quoi les
gens penser ce qu'ils veulent c'est à
l'envi dû dire ça elle le dit bien sûr
elle pense qu'elle veut si elle te dit
que les femmes font la cuisine et bain
le dit elle oblige pas les femmes à le
faire elle le fait elle même fait ce
qu'elle veut dire si son rêve c'est pas
des airs 6 mai après dilution de sexiste
et c'est du réalisme dans 98% des foyers
c'est les femmes qu'il faut en manger
si c'est pas d'accord mais c'est bah oui
c'est que la naissance à corcelles et
elles ne sont pas forcément soumise
moncany des vitrines voilà à aia d'aig
alors non vraiment c'est une phrase qui
est strictement aucune importance et du
tout qu'il faut pas prendre au pds est
absolument ridicule et quant à la dame
qui dit qu'il faut que retour au xvème
siècle viennent nous xvème siècle sépare
même son 15ème siècle avait une parfaite
égalité dans le peuple entre les alliés
et bien connu
question attention gilles c'est bon pour
toi c moi pour toit dans quel programme
corinne masiero at elle montré sa
poitrine et le jour du seigneur groland
le magazine de la santé au capitaine
maxime à zéro la star de capitaine
marleau qui était l'invité de l'émission
et on peut dire que c'était pas vraiment
une promo classique puisqu'elle nous a
dévoilé un truc d'elle à la débrouille
les regarder se donne lire ce que vous
en pensez puisque groland n'a rien foot
est regardé par quel bonheur de recevoir
l'interprète de capitaine maroilles
mossawa ville août vont-ils nous
réchauffer dans le froid de ces grèves
scandaleuse un des privilégiés du
service public
ça me fait pas rire là non ça je peux
pas laisser dire ça je suis désolé dans
20 ans ça va être quoi
des millions de clochards est clocharde
dans la rue ça va être sa réforme de la
retraite de merde qui nous prépare c'est
bien la dernière fois que nous recevons
une actrice ainsi elle se met à penser
maintenant on sait que fois leurs manies
vous le dois faire vous vous truc de
merde vous est permis
tu fis way dégoûté tiens
[Applaudissements]
vous imaginez
pour lui de 0,2 capitaine marleau qu'est
ce que vous en pensez ça c'est pour
dénoncer la réforme des retraites et
gilles verdez moi je trouve ça vulgaire
c'est moi non mais elle a le droit dans
les gestes dans le crash adam même dans
le la manière d'exposer son corps je
trouve que en fait pour sa cause elle va
beaucoup trop loin et elle dessert ce
qu'elle veut dire elle est trop
excessive
c'est ce que ça veut dire ça c'est les
personnalités associatives jean-michel
merde sauf que ces ongs roland de faire
dans la caricature de l'outrance jo il
ya des gens qui te dit que tu es trop
donc après ils n'ont pas compris la cour
des grands sur le tro l'excès c'est sur
30 mois l'algérie sûr que ça n'a pas plu
non alors d'abord je trouve que sur la
forme elle a une très belle poitrine et
ensuite sur le fond l'épilation
non mais ça moi je trouve que ça fait
mal et en fait cette image ne me choque
pas du tout et je la trouve plutôt très
belle et très séduisante en revanche
après sur le fond effectivement c'est
l'adn grolandais un peu comme charlie
donc on est dans le jura boutique zara
qui est mal exactement hara kiri
on est dans le trash après moi je ne
suis absolument pas d'accord avec ce
qu'elle dit sur le sur le fond mais
c'est pas grave je m'en fout en fait
elle a le droit de le dire voilà bien un
employé par sortir le dire donc ça me
gêne moins dans marleau certaines leurs
proches de politisée à outrance le
personnage de monde mais pierre de
meuron beaucoup plus qu'avant allez
gilles et maxi vous êtes sauvés question
qu'a déclaré le président du groupe m6 à
propos de l'émission une ambition intime
de karine marchand
le concept est respectée même les
audiences sont intimes j'espère qu'elle
va refaire de la politique on n'est pas
sûr de refaire une nouvelle saison où
c'est la meilleure animatrice de la
chaîne alors jean-louis prado on n'est
pas sur ma fin de saison
non mauvaise réponse
enfin faire quand on va en faire la
politique
à bombay la cata du ce matin le grand
patron du groupe m6 nicolas de tavernost
est l invité sur france info nicolas de
tavernost a commenté les audiences
d'ambition est une émission de karine le
marchand
il veut bien que l'émission continue
mais à une condition essart est dur
d'avoir des politiques parce que je vous
dis à part la en 2022 quand ça va être
les élections je vois pas qui va s'y
coller maintenant et puis c'est pas
assez fort et un concept qui fait un
million et demi je pense à une ambition
est imé qui revient malgré tout ça c'est
surprenant est ce que vous avez continué
ambition ultime jeu lire c'est un
concept mais c'est surtout une
animatrice et un invité
quand on fait de la politique ça marche
très bien quand on a fait des acteurs ça
marche et moins bien donc j'espère que
karim va refaire de la politique
w9 serait un laboratoire maintenant et
qui testera des programmes de w9 pour
les mettre ensuite sur m6 un manière
aussi de dire qu'il n'a pas qu'il fait
les derniers c'est vrai il est
extrêmement franc bus avec la d'ornano
il dit la vérité
question une auditrice ap le repas parce
que son enfant
oulala voulait la regarder en train de
quoi en train de faire caca et il est en
train de se maquiller en train de faire
l'amour
voilà mais ce n'est pas les caisses aux
sommets alors c'est pas les mêmes voilà
plein de son mari porte ses sous
vêtements
son voisin et naturistes son patron et
le saut dit cyril hanouna il ne faut pas
leur en voulais la regarder pharmapack
du coup non non mais pourtant oui jean
michel bélot
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
le regarder mourir dans l'europe il ya
une mère de famille ça fait énormément
réagir ce qui a posé une question un peu
déplacée qui nous a pas mal étonné c'est
la question sexo du jour je vous laisse
écouter et vous raillez c'est regarder
alors aujourd'hui vous allez répondre à
une question d'une maman c'est hélène
qui nous a écrit pour nous a rapporté en
fait la question que lui a posé son fils
de 10 ans joe lally bonjour catherine
mon fils de 10 ans pose pas mal de
questions ces derniers temps autour de
la sexualité la dernière en date c'est
de me demander si son père et moi avions
encore l'âge de faire l'amour
si oui qu'en été la dernière fois zébré
cyr et si la prochaine fois je pouvais
le prévenir pour qu'ils regardent et
apprennent comment on fait alors j'ai
pas su qu'on lui réponde catherine
corrège dû faire selon vous non non on
parle c'est incroyable ça promet alors
c'est normal moi je voulais quand
j'étais petit quand j'avais besoin d'en
bas quand j'étais petit qu'on avait dix
ans pour me renseigner sur la chose
savais que mon grand père il avait des
playboy et des cassettes donc de taper
boys et la journée un peu au lieu d'un
pea et olé olé et il savait qu'il avait
des cassettes aussi donc j'allais dans
sa chambre quand t'étais pas là et je
récupère et l'écart 7 et doivent
maintenant les mots me sont beaucoup
plus courts plus ouverts à tout ça il
pose la question ouvertement mois la
grève osé le faire avec ma mère est
arrivé un truc de ouf mon nom commençons
avec une cassette porno ah oui gt gt
bon j'avais je sais de quel âge il sait
18-17 vous étiez grand déjà ouais bah
oui créé s'avéra unis j'avais ramené une
meuf à la maison et est donc il y avait
et mais bon j'ai ramené de 9 à la maison
et en fait après je suis allé chez les
ch et d'un copain tout ça et la meuf
m'appelle de sur le bas sur le téléphone
ce qui est pas les portables sur le
téléphone de mon pote enfin de chez lui
elle me dit oui chez maison est touché
dans ta chambre et j'ai trouvé une
cassette est en fait que c'était une
cassette un peu fade un film tu vois et
là je fais away laisse tomber ça mon
père c'est ouf
et je n'ai plus jamais revu grande
dérouillée j'ai près que mon papa c'est
ça je regardais des films un peu olé olé
j'étais très très jeunes joueurs disant
très très jeune il a réveillé ses potes
on avait fait tourner des cassettes dans
le dab dans le quartier on avance sur
mega cd cassettes je mets dans le
domaine dans le magnétoscope et c'est un
monsieur qui s'ouvre est comme ça à
clapet en vhs et en fait la banda s'est
enroulé dans le truc juste quand mon
père il monte les marches la bande était
obligé en galère avec le maître que je
peux pas manger lorsqu'on m'a dit c'est
quoi ça il a sorti la cassette il ma
course et pendant trois heures